bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
magazine culturel trois invités ce soir
alain courbis le nouveau directeur de
l'espace culturel leconte de lisle de
saint paul qui viennent nous parler de
sa quinzaine théâtrale autres invités de
l'ouest stéphane bulteau du séchoir avec
son leu tempo festival du 10 au 13 mai
le spectacle est dans la rue autrefois
invités de ce culture première vanessa
cazals elle en est à sa 11e édition de
vita dance 2 m
deuxième des dix ans de vie la danse la
danse une passion chevillée au corps
mais elle n'est pas tout seul a lancé
jean-paul mais l'adq culture première
sur réunion 1ère bonsoir merci à tous à
tout plutôt d'être là merci à vincent
thierry qui nous accompagnent la
technique ce soir pourquoi merci à tout
parce que c'est une émission un peu
particulière ce soir hélas à cause du
basculement de la route du littoral à
nos invités a dû rebrousser chemin
devant des embouteillages qui engorgent
les axes de l'ouest de saint paul en
particulier alain courbis bonsoir alors
exceptionnellement vous serez donc par
téléphone formule que je n'aime pas
beaucoup mais enfin oui désolé données
vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas être des
zones et ce sont les aléas de la vie
donc vous n'êtes pas avec nous depuis
votre structure l'espace culturel
leconte de lisle à saint paul vous voilà
revenu aux commandes du sud une nouvelle
structure depuis quelques semaines vous
avez pris vos marques
oui ça fait déjà maintenant deux mois
depuis le 15 février que j'ai eu le
bonheur d'être retenu à la direction de
cette belle structure sur laquelle
effectivement voilà j'ai dû prendre du
temps pour voilà renouer des contacts
avec tous les partenaires je reçois
beaucoup beaucoup d'artistes avec
évidemment l'optique de
pluridisciplinarité du lieu donc musique
théâtre danse mais aussi cinéma et des
projets de conférences d'expositions
d'arts plastiques et d'événements hors
les murs aussi puisque
voilà l'espace sort bien souvent de ces
murs où nos salles sont de petites
jauges nous avons deux salles de
spectacles de 165 et 145 places sur
lesquels voilà certains spectacles ne
peuvent pas entrer nous essayons aussi
de travailler sur le terrain avec les
associations dans les quartiers etc
à vous entendre vous avez vraiment
retrouver le moral absolument oui oui
c'est très c'est très motivant voilà
j'ai une très bonne collaboration avec
tous les tous les services un qui sont
partenaires de ce lieu et il ya une
vraie une vraie volonté de le dynamiser
de lui donner encore plus de visibilité
et plus de proposer une offre culturelle
de qualité aussi bien intra muros que
hors les murs sur le territoire de la
ville de saint paul est aussi des des
communes du tc eau qui est partenaire du
lieu vous pouvez dire extra muros un ça
existe de la musique du théâtre du
cinéma et un coup de maître
demain sur le parking de l'espace
culturel avec la sortie d'un nouvel
album et quel nouvel album et quel
chanteur oui bah c'est un grand honneur
que nous chez daniel waro de venir
célébrer avec nous la sortie de son
nouvel album mon qui est dans les bacs
depuis quelques jours et ça faisait
quand même sept ans qu'il n'y avait pas
vu de de nouvel album en tout cas avec
de nouvelles compositions puisqu'il y
avait un live kabar qui était sorti il
ya quatre ans donc c'est un véritable
événement voilà daniel revient d'une
très belle tournée avec jean-marie barre
et quand a conduit dans pas mal de
villes françaises
je crois qu'il repart au moins de juin
sur un gros festival rio loco qui
travaille sur la thématique des îles de
l'océan indien dans la ville de toulouse
un très beau festival au bord de la
garonne et donc c'est une chance pour
nous de pouvoir l'accueillir et nous
avons voulu que ce soit un événement
populaire donc un concert gratuit dans
la cour de l'espace et non pas dans la
salle et avec la complicité des services
municipaux donc les rues seront rendues
piétonnes à partir de 16h demain autour
de l'espace et du cachet culture lâche
le risque est également partenaire de
l'événement pour que la fête soit
complète
alors vous vous attendez certainement
avoir beaucoup de monde oui alors
évidemment les premiers arrivés seront
les mieux placés le concert va démarrer
à partir de 20h et
15 heures jusqu'à 23 heures
oui au moins enfin voilà on ne peut pas
préjuger de la durée du concert mais
enfin on sait que on sait que daniel est
généreux et que voilà il a il a un gros
répertoire et puis là je crois qu'il a
aussi beaucoup de personne d'autre
darty ce qu'il a envie d'inviter au delà
de son propre groupe donc voilà l'on
sait vraiment ce soit une soirée c'est
votre prolonge c'est vraiment un gros à
faire quoi
oui oui oui on peut à oui s'il ya des
invités en plus donc 23 heures c'est
vraiment j'allais dire une heure moins
que raisonnable ça peut aller jusqu'à
minuit voilà en espérant évidemment que
le bouton souhaite la partie c'est vrai
que depuis hier et aujourd'hui le temps
est un petit peu mias heures jusqu'à
samedi au moins
oui et on espère que tout ça va va
partir dès demain matin pour nous
permettre de chaque fête soit réussie de
mâchoire alors sans dévoiler tout vous
avez écouté le moment je les ai écoutés
attentivement la depuis sa présentation
le rôle lors d'une conférence de presse
à bois rouge mardi matin et c'est vrai
que je l'apprécient beaucoup voilà je
trouve qu'il est bon il y a des il ya
douze originalité voilà des traits
beauté et puis un important travail vos
cannes notamment sur les polyphonies
avec un groupe un groupe qui entourent
daniel n'en dit pas plus dans une map le
site handiplage nous avons les travaux
auditeurs de découvrir je pense ces
jours ci sur vos jours alors ils vont
non seulement d'aider découvrir les
chansons sonos d'amener sera notre
invité la semaine prochaine dans culture
première la même heure que vous voilà
donc ils seront tous à lécousse j'espère
dit à l'ats courbis on va parler quand
même de votre quinzaine de théâtre vous
avez des choses mais beaucoup de choses
vous avez une dizaine de représentations
si je dis pas de bêtises et d'entrée moi
je suis conquis par ce que j'ai lu des
rêves dans le sable ça a l'air d'être
féerique
c'est un spectacle complètement c'est
eric par une compagnie qui s'appelle
sable d'avril et
donc voilà c'est un spectacle qui va
ouvrir cette quinzaine théâtrale que
nous organisons en partenariat avec le
festival comme idi de saint joseph
vous connaissez l'ampleur du travail qui
est fait par ce festival à saint joseph
où je crois d'ailleurs même que la la
plupart des spectacles doivent être
complet donc le public aura
en tout cas de la possibilité pour ceux
qui ne peuvent pas des à saint joseph de
d'attraper si j'ose dire
neuf représentations de neuf spectacles
différents sur saint paul à l'espace
parmi parmi des très belles propositions
où ils se
ce spectacle lundi soir est un spectacle
de dessins sur le sable qui donne vie à
des personnages étonnants et c'est
vraiment un univers de conte très
poétique
quelque chose qui a été primé au
festival d'avignon 2014 alors et puis
vous avez quelque chose si qui est pas
mal c'est ma classe hip hop ça s'adresse
à mon avis à tout public ça oui ma
classe hip hop c'est une une jeune femme
c'est la compagnie kader aoun production
qui nous propose un voyage à travers les
époques et des techniques en fait elle
retrace l'histoire de cette danse de rue
depuis sa naissance dans dans des
quartiers aux états unis et elle nous
retrace en un peu moins d'une heure
l'épopée de du hip hop c'est un
spectacle dont on nous a dit le plus
grand bien aussi elle est tout seul sur
scène elle s'appelle céline lefèvre et
donc elle se produira le vendredi 28
avril à 20 heures
alors là je suis surpris par votre
programmation c'est que vous proposez
les contes d'hoffmann du théâtre lyrique
on s'intéresse encore au théâtre lyrique
en 2017
ah ben non seulement s'y intéresse
encore je peux vous dire que ce
spectacle est déjà content les noms oui
oui ça a été un des premiers spectacles
à être complet et
je pense qu'il y à une véritable demande
de public pour de l'art d'eric bon celui
ci et en plus complètement théâtralisée
c'est une compagnie très importante qui
s'appelle la compagnie l'envolée lyrique
et c'est une
c'est une adaptation très personnelle de
des contes d'hoffmann d'offenbach et je
crois qu'il ya une véritable demande et
d'ailleurs je pense profiter de la très
belle acoustique de notre salle alain
péters singes notre salle de l'espace
leconte de lisle la très belle
acoustique et du très beau piano que
nous avons pour proposer de temps en
temps des petites formes lyrique au
public puisqu'on en recense une vraie
demande
il ya finalement très peu d'offres dans
ce domaine rien une pièce qui est qu un
titre un peu
j'allais dire provoquant jeu but très
bien ma mère à dimanche
c'est le 5 mai c'est une fin qui est
tout seul en scène c'est juniville r oui
alors
oui julie gilbert s'éteint
je pense que c'est un spectacle très
drôle on va dire parmi les parmi les
références un petit peu de cette actrice
on peut ça peut faire penser à des films
de woody allen ou ou des ambiances un
peu d'almodovar en même temps de de
dessin animé c'est un spectacle qui a
reçu plusieurs prix sur plusieurs
festivals des prix du jury des prix du
public au festival rire en scène c'est
un spectacle le comique c'est une
comédie mais qui s'adresse quand même à
un public à partir de 14 ans c'est le
spectacle qui clôturera la quinzaine le
vendredi 5 mai à 20 heures
arias de la danse aussi la couleur de
famille au chan qu'on connaît bien la
réunion alors voilà tout de suite après
la quinzaine théâtre l on va enchaîner
avec trois spectacles de danse de très
haut niveau couleur deux femmes c'était
la première création de la compagnie
ouïe chan en 1994 à l'époque où les
pratiquants de danse contemporaine à la
réunion passé un peu pour des
extraterrestres et c'est une une
création qu'elle a décidé de reprendre
depuis l'année dernière avec une
nouvelle distribution et voilà il a
complètement retravaillée 7,7 création
de danse contemporaine pour un trio
féminin et ce sera à voir le mardi 16
mai à 20 heures
il ya le prix du public d'avignon 2016
avec double c'est la compagnie des
sources
oui mon a dit grand bien
ah oui oui alors c'est un spectacle
aussi je crois pour lequel il faut
réserver très vite puisqu'ils ont eu
également un prix du public en avignon
un spectacle de danse qu'il ya eu une
très bonne presse
un peu partout c'est difficile d'en
parler je crois qu'il faut qu'il faut
pour ne pas le voir de voir et puis il
ya des comoriens ces deux là voilà dont
on est dans la danse métissée et puis
des comoriens qui travaille entre la
danse contemporaine et le hip hop c'est
un spectacle a aussi été primé dans un
festival international pas sport tas à
maurice en mai 2016 en tout cas c'est
une une compagnie de l'océan indien qui
nous invitons en partenariat avec le
théâtre des bambous d'ailleurs tout
comme la compagnie des sources
ces deux spectacles que nous mutualisons
avec le théâtre des bambous et ce qu'ils
permettent au public de l'est et de
l'ouest dans profitez donc des
spectacles de danse de de très haut
niveau dur d'y croire ça serait le
samedi 20 mai à 20 heures
or dit deux mots rapidement sur
génération maloya 3ème édition avec
firmin viry et ses invités oui alors le
principe de génération maloya qui
clôture en général le premier semestre
de l'espace et de la transmission entre
entre les grands les aînés du maloya et
des formations plus jeunes de
différentes générations donc là le le
parrain de cette soirée ça sera firmin
viry soirée qui se déroulera le samedi
27 mai donc à 19 heures et il y aura
quatre groupes invités un jeune groupe
de la saline qui n'est pas encore très
connu mais qui est à découvrir qui
s'appelle jimmy et l'esprit ce sont
aussi des artistes qui pratiquent aussi
le moringue et le maloya
on retrouvera avec plaisir voce acquis
et le groupe de marie claude lambert
une des filles de gramoun lélé qui a
sorti un album très remarqué l'année
dernière patrick manent grandes voix du
maloya
encore trop méconnu à mon avis qui a eu
un gros succès dernièrement chez nous
dans un spectacle fusion avec le
pianiste fabio marouvin et bibi tanga
chanteur africain dans une création mais
là il est dans sa formule traditionnelle
donc et puis mélange nation ne sait
combien peu un retour de stéphane
grondin à la tête de ce groupe qu'il
avait créée en 1995 donc il y à déjà
plus de vingt ans et qui a également
sorti un nouvel album l'année dernière
donc voilà je pense que c'est un beau
plateau maloya gratuit à partir de 19h
le samedi 27 mais là aussi dans dans la
cour de l'espace avec évidemment la rue
qui sera fermé voilà le quartier le
quartier en fête
pour clôturer ce premier semestre de
programmation en attendant que je puisse
lancer ma propre programmation sur le
deuxième semestre merci alain courbis un
merci à vous et à bientôt
[Musique]
allez y à bastia maïdo par les pays ne
veulent nouveau drapeau la réunion
yoshikawa you devant la voyais aval la
voile bateaux devant la voyais à ben la
voilà même bateau la loi volts rails en
ciel petit magot et la mer et fanny
jandrain ciel bodygroom la clé
cela me donne comme la braise petit
carène
au coeur prenez-en toute réponse depuis
30 ans
wen est étonnant mappy ou playboy l'anc
est nommé
abo
[Musique]
m
mais où
[Musique]
moi
banimmo
[Musique]
culture première sur réunion 1ère vous
avez bien sûr reconnu daniel waro un
extrait de son dernier album moment et
c'était france pour soir vanessa cazals
et bien vent soir ça fait un an qu'il ya
un an de cela vous étiez là dans ce
studio pas nous parler donc de 8 à
danser la douzième édition la danse une
passion qui vous habite
c'est ça depuis depuis l'âge de 12 ans
et vous n'avez jamais arrêté non je ne
ferai jamais je pense pas j'aimerais pas
alors dites-nous ce que c'est exactement
vita dance et c'est beaucoup de choses à
la fois c'est il ya des invités il y a
des des stages enfin il ya quelque chose
à voir comment c'est peut-être par le
local qu'est ce qu'il ya
le canon qu'est ce que vous avez comme
invités locaux écoutez cette année c'est
vraiment un vital ans sous le signe et
sous les couleurs du local j'ai réservé
une petite surprise en fait à toutes les
personnes qui suivent le festival depuis
des années et qui aime l'émission danse
avec les stars
parce que j'ai osé on veut dire ça j'ai
osé le pari cette année et jose rozo et
je me suis dit ça y est c'est le moment
on peut le faire et j'ai vraiment envie
de le faire on va faire danser nos stars
à nous nos stars locales
donc du coup je me suis lancé ce pari
j'ai contacté plusieurs célébrités
connues à la réunion de tous les milieux
humoristes chanteurs miss etc et je leur
ai proposé
voilà deux furent quelques jours un gros
défi c'était je vous donne six semaines
je vous offre la formation
je vous met à disposition des danseurs
professionnels des pointures dans leur
domaine ils vont vous prendre en main et
ils vont vous former sur une
chorégraphie de 2 minutes 30 que vous
allez présenter lors d'un concours
unique le vendredi 12 mai
et pour tenter de remporter un chèque de
1500 euros pour l'association caritative
de votre choix alors des blés de les
inviter nos stars locales
on peut les connaître ou alors vous pour
faire garder la surprise
mais nous dire par exemple sûr que ce
qu'est ce qu'un condensé du hip hop du
séga dumas le gars du tango alors oui on
peut en parler
donc lors de la conférence de presse
vendredi dernier que j'ai donné au lodge
tamarins où on a beaucoup mis à part
dont on en parle voilà alors j'ai donné
une conférence de presse à la semaine
dernière et j'ai justement c'était
l'occasion de donner au grand public le
nom des stars quitter tant attendu donc
c'était à cette occasion là donc on à
miss réunion qui va danser bien
évidemment avec cet homme en haut avec
s'étaleront oui et donc ça sera des
danses latines américaine avec son
partenaire jérémy fontaine nous avons
aurélie béton qui animatrice télé et qui
elle va danser avec chris bryant et là
ça a été la surprise pour elle a 7 ans
dépassera plus de style hip hop vous
voilà oui elle a eu la même réaction
donc on a également lino lino humoriste
comédien qui lui a cette particularité
suite à un accident de la route
impliquant pour trois ans du kop qui est
porteur d'un handicap qui s'en sort très
bien
exactement qui s'en sort très bien et
qu'il a va danser avec flora baptiste
qui elle est spécialisée en latino et en
jazz donc qui nous a concocté une super
chorégraphie on a également marie alice
sinaman qui connu comme nous risquons de
feu voilà et qui elle va danser avec le
roi de la salsa à la réunion qui est
saint-just et là elle va nous danser une
kizomba oulala ça va être chaud
exactement
nous avons maroni maroni qui lui danse
avec maeva lebrun
et ça va être du jazz contemporain mike
de yolo 9 7 4 qui est lui plus connu sur
les réseaux sociaux pour la réunion by
night
l'ue va danser avec bibiana guillame et
du tango argentin et pour finir nous
avons misty la chanteuse qui est la
seconde elle va pas danser du séga elle
va danser elle devait danser d'abord
avec juanito du tango argentin mais
finalement celui ci un petit imprévu il
y avait un petit rebondissement dans
l'aventuré elle va danser avec sébastien
payette qui prépare de la valse d'accord
vous c'est tout à fait en phase d'un
vaste il a donc pas boire jantes un bon
c'est pas du tout la même chose
auriez vous vous dansez pas et moi non
cette année je ne danse pas j'ai dansé
li ya trois ans de cela avec maxime
dereymez j'ai eu cet honneur de pouvoir
faire une chorégraphie avec lui la
première fois où ils sont venus à la
réunion
j'ai dansé l'année dernière avec toute
ma famille qui était la présente pour
l'occasion où on a fait vraiment un
spectacle de 15 minutes et ça a été un
rêve quelque part de pouvoir partager ça
mais cette année j'ai une organisation
beaucoup plus importante que les autres
années je vous parlerai du reste du
programme et ceux qui ne me permet pas
du coude
alors justement le reste du programme en
dehors donc de ces personnalités
qu'est-ce qu'il va y avoir alors il ya
beaucoup de nouveautés cette année donc
va tout d'abord le vita dance avec nos
stars pays
je viens d'expliquer le 12 mai mais
avant cela le vice à danser du 8 au 14
mai donc il y a
du tout cette semaine là donc ça va
commencer à partir du lundi 8 mai sur
tout le territoire de la possession donc
la ville met en place
nous sommes à disposition toutes les
infrastructures de la ville
on va proposer avec l'association de de
toutes les associations de danse de la
ville un programme de stage donc plus de
40 heures de stage de danse ouvert au
tout public entre lui et non pas gratuit
mais ou tarif symbolique de 2 euros donc
vraiment accessible et pour permettre
aux enfants aux adultes de venir
découvrir ce que nous on propose à la
possession toutes les disciplines de
danse
ça va des danses latino hip hop à la
pole dance à la country à la line dance
et il faut vraiment venir voir le
planning qui est sur notre site internet
tempo tiré dans six académies point
heureux parce que voilà il ya un
programme très sympa qu'on vous a
concocté pour vous poser une question
peut-être pioche si je veux apprendre le
churn stone ah ça c'est une ancienne
danse justement mais une très belle
danse néanmoins que j'adore et que
j'affectionne donc il faut venir me voir
ma corde en feront un peu dans ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'on peut
pendant cette semaine la silice et
autres charleston sont en vie ou sa
discipline après c'est vrai qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de d'école qui vont ceux
spécifiés dans le charleston
c'est peut-être pas non plus ce qui est
demandé à l'heure actuelle c'est un père
je vois la meilleure en cours
particulier aucun souci donc ça c'est
possible nous verrons je veux apprendre
ce que l'on veut si on a une danse qui
nous plaît mais qui en donnant bien
évidemment en dehors de ce cadre là
voilà vous voulez vous voir une fait du
sur mesure
du sur mesure et les danses en ligne
aussi alors ça c'est marrant pas appuyé
je vais peut-être pas à une bêtise mais
les dents s'enlise souvent ce sont les
seniors pour ne pas dire des personnes
âgées
ah c'est vrai que on a beaucoup de
seniors et de personnes n'ont peut-être
à partir de 30 ans 35 ans on a pas mal
de personnes qui essayent la danse en
ligne
parce que depuis quelques temps il faut
dire que ça s'est pas mal moderniser ils
font pas que c'est pas que de la country
la danse en ligne donc
c'est pas ma spécialité mais de ce que
je connais non j'en parle
ils font maintenant danse en ligne sur
tous styles de musique des plus modernes
des plus rock des plus jazz de ce qu'on
entend aussi à la radio actuellement
donc il ya tous les styles pour tous les
âges il est accessible vraiment il
ralliera des concours pendant cette
semaine un juge a bien évidemment ça
c'est pour moi le coeur du festival et
c'est pour ça que j'ai créé le festival
en 2006 à la base c'est que moi je viens
de ce milieu là les danses de
compétition et quand j'ai créé mon école
à la possession je me suis dit il faut
dynamiser ce côté là et que je puisse
proposer à mes élèves des rencontres et
des échanges et avec tous les danseurs
qui font aussi des danses de compétition
sur l'île il y en a donc il y aura
l'afrique du sud invités d'honneur avec
25 compétiteurs qui viennent plus tous
les danseurs de lille donc une belle
rencontre au programme avec des battles
de solo dance des danses en couple et et
voilà tout ça vous tente c'était bonnet
bulteau vous qui venez du séchoir les la
danse là comment elle allait propose
vanessa pourquoi pas la seule chose que
je découvrais qu est froissé que c'est
une semaine nous est moi aussi pas mal
mobilisé on pouvait partir après avoir
pour un cours particulier va reprendre
le be bop par exemple ouais ou me
remettre aux claquettes belle tête à
tête vous faites ça c'est particulier
mais je connais des profs évidemment
qu'il veut
alors donc il va voir le camp ce
concours et quand est-ce qu'on connaîtra
les gagnants au vin ou le gagnant alors
il ya le coup la partie concours trophée
vita dance donc qui va se faire le
vendredi la journée et le samedi la
journée les finales le soir mais il y à
un concours que j'ai créé que j'ai lancé
cette année et qui la touchent pas
seulement
les personnes qui est bon dans des cours
de danse dans les écoles de danse est
vraiment pour tout public
c'est très simple c'est le premier à la
réunion concours just dance le jeu vidéo
donc bon oui le jeu vidéo just dance
bien voilà donc c'était un jeu vidéo qui
rencontre un succès planétaire
il suffit d'avoir la console le jeu une
télé et devant son écran on lance la
chorégraphie et il suffit de reproduire
en fait les mêmes nous on n'y met deux
camps sont ici on danse en histoire de
karaoké dansant
c'est ça mais du coup on a un score
final qui qui va nous permettre en fait
d'accéder aux compétitions donc just
dance c'est ça existe déjà en concours
sous forme de world cup
la dernière était à paris en février
dernier et à la réunion on n'a pas le
confondre
de plus le progrès avant de participer
donc du coup j'ai dit cette année il
faut que la réunion puisse être présente
en tout cas au sélectif just dance à
paris pour pouvoir avoir l'opportunité
de participer à la world cup
il y a énormément je le sais et
notamment dans mes propres élèves mais
je n'en doute pas ailleurs des fans des
jeunes qui sont fans de ce jeu et on
leur offre donc la possibilité de
participer à ce grand concours avec des
phases de qualification la première
semaine du mois de mai et la grande
finale le jeudi 11 mai au gymnase à
narcisse à la possession et la
possibilité de gagner son billet d'avion
pour aller représenter justement la
réunion et paris lors des prochains
sélectif forcer des gens venaient
d'avoir des informations il était
évident qu'elle numéro alors on n'a pas
de numéro n'a le site internet
on est dans le digital désolé voilà donc
ce tempo tirer dans ce tir et académies
point est re dont toutes les infos fiche
d'inscription en ligne
rappelez-nous donc les dogues de vita
dance 8 au 14 mai à la possible à la
récession en particulier au gymnase
narcisse mais ce sera partout sur toute
la commune sur toute la commune
exactement et on n'a pas oublié aussi
les seniors
on en parlait tout à l'heure qui
clôtureront ce festival avec un grand
bal le dimanche après midi
merci vanessa cazals
jon l'avant du bateau mouille sa bonne
amie d'enfance dont il a eu l'aval de
mon patron d'apple n'a pas mandat l'eau
[Musique]
c'est la vie
josiane moisi nations en battant des
mains dans un livre propose aux
particuliers demandant un niveau auprès
de particuliers ensemble immobilier
[Musique]
culture première sur réunion 1ère 18h45
dans culture première j'habite deux
modes de monde et vanessa cassation dans
cette seconde médaille or pendant cette
semaine de vie tendance ah ben on aura
beaucoup d'associations une ou deux qui
vont venir en spectacle les compères
créole par exemple et qui donneront
aussi des stages d'initiation
oui oui merci s'évanouit bulteau bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez fait le déplacement
depuis sa le sait ça merci pour ce que
vous êtes courageuse avec la circulation
qu'il ya en ce moment je suppose que ça
n'a pas dû être agréable c'est surtout
un peu long très long je m'en doute le
le tempo festival alors c'est la
première édition 19e édition cette année
en 2010 est l'année prochaine ce feu
d'artifice sur l'année prochaine ces
feux d'artifice en tout cas c'est
essayons de marquer quelque chose
l'année prochaine j'ai l'impression
qu'en feuilletant donc le fascicule que
j'ai entre les mains que il ya beaucoup
plus de spectacles de l'année dernière
où c'est une impression alors en nombre
de spectacles je sais pas s'il y en a
plus en tout cas ce qu'on a essayé de
faire cette année alors l'an dernier le
format du festival avait été un tout
petit peu réduit exemple une soirée
avait été supprimée décaler le festival
on continue sur ce format là cette année
on démarre le mercredi soir puis ensuite
le jeudi le vendredi le samedi toute la
journée et la clôture du festival avec
la fête d'un chemin avant c'était plus
long ça commençait plutôt tendance à
démarrer le mardi soir et pour des
raisons budgétaires je suppose comme
tout le monde
non on est obligé de resserrer un petit
peu les choses l'année dernière avait
été aussi un petit peu resserré la
programmation rue la programmation dans
l'espace public gratuite ouverte à tous
et du coup là cette année on a voulu
remettre aussi un petit peu de de
quantité et de qualité dans cette
programmation rue parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que c'était une partie
qu'ils aient vraiment c'était une partie
très importante de l'adn du festival
aussi sûr que le tempo sellal à la
coexistence ou en tout cas la
complémentarité entre des spectacles de
rue gratuits des spectacles en salle
avec une billetterie mais des
billetteries très progressive avec des
places on va dire qu'il soit notre 5 et
22 euros
alors c'est marrant parce que ces
spectacles de rue enfin je veux dire
c'est cette façon de procéder
c'est souvent dans l'ouest un ou dans le
sud il ya eu un moment dans l'est ça ne
nie rien pas la paix les gens c'est à la
ville de sa muse la cinor s'il souhaite
qu'on mette en place un événement autour
des arts de la rue sur leur territoire
on est là voilà bien mais j'espère que
la paix sera entendu et grands tous les
cas on pourra avoir le même genre de
spectacle que vous ça fait vingt ans ça
fait déjà un bon moment
alors quand on nous la première page
marquée si a causé ensemble mouvement
croisé sommet théâtr'ouvert casse les
cuts un poil et impôts vive
t'es pas fait peut-être là qu il veut
alors vous voyez vraiment pas te faire
péter la colla web c'est un moment c'est
un moment fort aussi quand même dans la
vie de la vie de l'avion
dans la vie de notre de notre territoire
donc nous le séchoir on agit toute
l'année avec une programmation toute
l'année de la diffusion de spectacles du
travail avec les marmailles de
l'éducation artistique et culturelle des
spectacles aux vagues mais c'est vrai
que le tempo reste comme ça une espèce
de temps très très fort dans la vie de
notre ville vous parlais justement de
ville il ya ti doré en ville alors c'est
marrant parce que quand tous ces gens là
sont vivants ont dit voilà on les
connaît sans plus
mais dès lors qu'ils sont morts tout de
suite ça prend une dimension
particulière en jeu par alain peters et
la maintenant en ce moment c'est ty
aurait donc c'est madoré ça c'est un
travail en tout cas mené par par tricot
de peau eric lebaut et marine charles a
accompagné du comédien nicolas givran
c'est un travail autour du répertoire d'
henri madoré je ne sais pas si on peut
complètement dire un hommage car ces
trois là sont quand même un petit peu
déjanté on va le dire comme ça
d'accord je suppose que ce spectacle
aussi des chants t il et il est en cours
de création
enfin ce sera les premières
représentations au tempo c'est une des
créations du festival donc là ils sont
actuellement d'ailleurs en train de
travailler à trois-bassins face à kazan
vous avez déjà participé déjà vu le
tempo festival
en fait je crois que ça tombe toujours
pendant un festival aussi
voilà vous fait concurrence à bon nombre
je pense pas parce qu'on il en rajoutait
concurrence vous n'avez pas la
possibilité en termes de calendrier
il existe bien des doigts la prochaine
fois vous vous entendre et je crois que
c'est une des difficultés de la réunion
pouvoir s'entendre sur le calendrier
au moins je trouve que ça se passe bien
si mal que ça ouais en tout cas ça
dialogue
en tout cas entre autres structures
culturelles sa dialogue à une très belle
photo
c'est les tambours de feu savez du pays
basque espagnol et des percussions et
des artifices vous allez mettre le feu à
la bulle ben oui ça enfin c'est le but
du jeu c'est le dire le le lancement de
la fête dans chemin on essaie toujours
de mettre une compagnie professionnelle
il ya tellement de monde à la fête d'un
chemin aujourd'hui un salaire qu'un
entre 15000 personnes à peu près qui
sont attendus pour ce défilé où on coupe
quand même la rue du général lambert qui
même si elle n'est plus la route
nationale reste quand même un extrait
très très passante donc c'est vrai que
ça
c'est un acte fort et militants de
couper la route et puis de l'investir
avec des artistes dont qu'ils ouvrent la
parade et ils sont suivis par des
associations de saint leu de tout le
territoire ouest voire même de toute la
réunion qui en profite pour continuer
dans cette parade en dansant entendez
batucada 11 ans voilà c'est un moment
comme ça un grand moment de fête
partagée par par des pratiquants comme
ça de d'activités artistiques
alors je vois avec plaisir est de plus
en plus des programmations donc des
structures qu'il ya des artistes de
l'océan indien il y en avait déjà
mais de plus en plus venant de maillots
tout des comores là vous avez ou tung ou
donc c'est du hip hop évolution venant
de mayotte dont quatre jeunes danseurs
et qui viennent donc parfois je pense
dans la réunion ils peuvent évolution
est déjà venue à la réunion et pop
évolution c'est une association qui
travaille autour de la danse hip hop de
rue à mayotte et qui avec certains
jeunes on va dire confie certains jeunes
à un chorégraphe pour monter des
spectacles sait pas encore exactement
une rue john lennon fessionnels la cecc
angie qui travaillent avec eux sur ce
sens ce spectacle-là et mais c'est vrai
que cette année en a on a une vraie
dimension océan indien qu'on a eu envie
d'assumer puisque on accueille aussi le
zip zap circus qu'il vient de cape town
on accueille des jeunes artistes
circassiens qui nous viennent des
tananarive
les mahorais effectivement de hip hop
solution avec ou tongs ou 11 heures à
gags magassa sur les cinq sens les
malgaches et puis on à la compagnie nos
artistes associés circonflexe avec leurs
créations l'appli dunn qui associe deux
circassiens réunionnais à circassiens
sud africain et un circassien malgache
la paix donne qui était en
en sortie 20 kg était en france
métropolitaine viapass oui ils
reviennent là d'une dune tourneur
métropole apparemment ça c'est plutôt
très très bien passé là ils reviennent
et puis ils vont nous refaire quelques
petites représentations à saint-leu où
il n'avait encore jamais joué bien donc
peut-être content qu'il soit là oui
ravie quand je les ai vus à aux bambous
me semble juste pas de bêtises oui
c'était bon bout qui tout ça alors
mahagaga pour revenir aux malgaches
je savais pas qu'il y avait aussi bien
des malgaches qui s'est intéressé au
cirque acrobatique du côté donc de la
capitale certainement il y en avoir
plein mais bon elles ne sont pas connues
alors ils sont pas connues et puis c'est
vrai que là on va dire la pratique
professionnelle des arts du cirque et
pas très très très ancienne par contre
ce qu'il ya donc à cape town ou away
tananarive parce qu'on peut faire quand
même un parallèle c'est quand même
depuis quasiment vingt ans qu'on appelle
des écoles de cirque social c'est-à-dire
des artistes de cirque qui se sont
installés dans des territoires et qui
utilise le cirque pour créer du lien
avec des jeunes sur caricature un peu un
peu désoeuvrés un peu comme said that
circus capetown ça a été la première
école de cirque en afrique du sud qui
mélangeait des artistes noirs et des
artistes blancs de révolution que c'est
bien aussi de soutenir ce type de
travail et ben on va dire que 20 ans
après de ces écoles de cirque et ben
commence à sortir des gens qui ont une
vraie technicité une vraie pratique de
ces 2 ses disciplines et qui commence à
avoir envie d'en faire leur métier
il est l'une des vocations du séchoir
qui est en train de devenir pôle
national cirque c'est d'accompagner ses
envies la d'accompagner ces artistes là
dans une structuration professionnelle
et donc de leur ouvrir entre autres
l'espace du tempo pour se présenter pour
se rencontrer du public et aussi
rencontrer des professionnels puisque on
accueille cette année une délégation
d'une quarantaine de professionnels qui
viennent sur le tempo dont une trentaine
de métropolitains et européens et une
dizaine de l'océan indien alors pôle
national sûr que c'est pour quand et
comment on obtient ce label
alors c'est un travail on va dire c'est
pousser plus que l'obtention d'un label
c'est la reconnaissance d'un travail
qu'est menée depuis plusieurs années par
par le séchoir sur les arts du cirque à
la réunion c'est pour quand
on espère normalement pour fin 2010 est
démis de début 2018
voilà on travaille là sur la rédaction
en fait de la convention qui va nous
lier avec l'ensemble de nos partenaires
pour les trois quatre prochaines années
nous réserver la primeur
quand ça se fait si ça se fait bien sûr
à qui je la réserve avec leurs premières
bien sûr pas rageant pour le malade
je me suis réengagé comme grain de sable
à réunion 1ère vous avez des
sud-africains aussi tant chez vous
connaissent à kazan et noir et blanc
mélangés à de plus en plus aussi ça se
voit parce que je crois qu'ils
attendaient ça aussi depuis longtemps
qu' il ya une révolution au niveau de la
mixité
we will un pied puis moi je trouve que
c'est important de présenter sur nos
scènes sur nos plateaux que ce soit dans
la rue quand on travaille dans la rue
mais c'est important de présenter des
artistes comme on dit entre guillemets
issus de la diversité ce qui s'il veut
absolument rien dire mais en tout cas
d'être moi j'ai enfin je trouve les des
plateaux parfois un tout petit peu trop
pâlichon à mon goût et je pense qu'il ya
tout un travail à faire pour remettre un
peu de couleur sur nos plateaux ne
serait ce que pour que pour que des
jeunes puissent aussi s'identifier ces
artistes là à voir se dire que c'est
possible pour eux d'en faire et que
c'est pas du tout aux réserves et je ne
sais quelle partie de la pop in alors
serge grondin est toujours là avec son
micro est toujours aussi caustique
on ne se détache line prend là nous il
ne repart pas vous et sergio nous
accompagne pendant tout le festival on
le retrouve au village du festival à
partir de 13 heures si je me trompe pas
pour un petit temps déçu des changes
comme ça sur le festival en lui on est
un peu un peu masochiste sur ce coup là
on lui laisse un espace en lui laisse un
micro et pendant une heure une heure et
demie il reçoit les artistes du festival
et il commente les spectacles vus
accompagnés par des journalistes pour
les petits pour le grand quoi que ça
fait toujours plaisir d'avoir un clown
hélas hélas le bail il vient d'où il
doit du portugal il vient du portugal
c'est un jeune prodige d'une vingtaine
d'années que moi j'avais découvert il ya
trois ans sur un festival de rue au
portugal et voilà qui est moi je trouve
une des plus belles choses que j'ai vues
comme clown dans la rue ces dernières
années vraiment vraiment je pense que je
n'étais pas la seule à avoir le coup de
coeur pour lui c'est quelqu'un qui avait
été approchée par un cirque du soleil
que cet appui qu elle souhaitait
continuer comme ça son travail qui a
quelqu'un qui a une capacité à réunir
autour de lui des centaines de gens
venir là les faire venir avec lui
puisqu'il construit toute une narration
en utilisant des spectateurs n'ont alors
rien à vous d'accord lui est bon et on
comprend et on sait internationale ouais
complètement c'est un s'est accumulée il
a accompagné d'un musicien et un petit
fond musical qui l'accompagnent mais il
n'y a pas de langue il arrive à
peut-être vous si vous venez à vous
prendrez puis à vous faire faire quelque
chose que vous auriez jamais pensé
pouvoir faire mais vous y amène avec une
tranquillité une humanité elle est assez
désarmante alors appel donc stéphane
bulteau queue leu leu tempo festival
c'est du 10 au 13 mai à saint leu dans
toute la ville s'est éclaté dans toute
la ville en à la rue général lambert
c'est bien ça je dis pas de bêtises et
que ça va être un grand moment de fête
et de partage
merci à vous deux d'être venus de si
loin pour parler donc bientôt de vos
activités merci à aussi à alain courbis
m'ont quitté dans son bureau
malheureusement un peu contrit mais
c'est quand même nous a parlé de ce qui
se passe chez lui à l'espace culturel on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau donc culture première avec comme
je le dis en invité principal le petit
castor ça fait un peu pompeux en invité
principal donc daniel
waro qui va nous parler donc de son
dernier album qui s'appelle moment et
avant de vous quitter vous informer que
le concert de frédéric joron thierry
collet tikok vellaye qui devait avoir
lieu le samedi 20 mai à 20h au théâtre
plein air de saint-gilles est annulé les
spectateurs ayant déjà acheté leur
billet sont invités à se faire
rembourser selon la procédure indiquée
sur le site internet des théâtres
départementaux bonne soirée sur réunion
1ère il est 18 heures 58 à la semaine
prochaine n'oubliez pas que vous
retrouvez claudio dans quelques instants
et après le journal de france info au
revoir au revoir culture première sur
réunion 1ère
[Musique]